hi in this video i'm going to talk about
co-immunoprecipitation so
co-immunoprecipitation is a very good
technique to study in vivo protein
protein interaction so insider cell if
we suspect that two proteins let's say
protein a and protein b interacts with
each other then we need to devise a
technique and think of a technique by
which we can show that protein a or
protein b is really interacting and
for this we have to do
co-immunoprecipitation now one thing we
should keep in mind that for this
co-immunoprecipitation we should have
antibody against both the proteins if we
don't have antibody against both the
proteins then this process is not
possible
so
for a co-immunoprecipitation
we have a cell
so let's say inside that cell protein a
and protein b
are interacting
we suspect that protein a and protein b
are interacting
so what we would do we would
lyse the cell and put it in a buffer and
then we would add a bead magnetic bead
containing antibodies against protein a
so here our
antibody
is anti-a
so anti-a antibody is linked with these
magnetic beads
so anti-a antibody
which are monoclonal antibodies
would bind with our protein a
and we don't even know that uh protein
is bound with protein b or protein a is
not bound with protein b let's say as
this is a monoclonal antibody against
protein a we are sure that our
magnetic bead containing this anti-a
antibody would bind with protein a
now what we would do we would centrifuge
this
total solution and after centrifugation
we would get a
fraction that is pull down fraction so
this is a pull down fraction so we
expect that these
magnetic bead along with this
anti-antibody would pull down a
so if
b protein b is interacting with protein
protein b is interacting with protein a
then we would expect that when we are
pulling down a with these antibody
coated beads
b is also pulled down with
uh the protein a
and if they are not interacting with
each other then we
would find that
uh that
b is not pulled down and b is not
present in the pull down fraction so in
order to detect whether b is present in
the pull down fraction or b is not
present in the pull up down fraction we
would proceed by these steps
so what we would do we would collect
this pull-down fraction and we would
process this pull-down fraction and load
it on a sds-page gel a protein gel and
we would run the protein gel
so after running the protein gel
what we would do we would perform a
wasting blot
and in this western blot we would give
the antibody against protein b
so basically
we pulled down a and now we are
performing the western blot
using the antibody against b
and
if in the western blot if in in the
western blot the diagram of the western
blot we can show that that uh in the
pull down fraction
uh b is present
then we can say
a and b are interacting so we have
pulled down a here and we have loaded
the pull down fraction here and we
expect that in the pull down fraction b
is present so b would be present in this
particular jail and
b would be blotted
in the pvdf membrane so when we put
antibody against b we can see band
against b so b
these bands here so these are the
loading controls like beta acting band
so these
bands
represent b over here
so from this particular
western blot uh profile we can say that
our protein p is actually present in
this pull down fraction so that is how
we can get an idea that whether two
proteins are interacting inside a cell
or not
so there could be two possibilities
either they are interacting they are not
interacting so let's say we have a
control acting band beta acting brand
and this bit acting band is a loading
control so it would be present in the
either conditions whether b is present
or whether b is not present so if b is
present we would get a positive band for
b when we are blotting
the gel
after running the pull down fraction
when we are blotting gel we would get a
positive band for b
and
if b is not present in the pull-down
fraction that means if we think that b
is not actually interacting with a then
what would happen there would be no band
for b but there would be
the loading control the
control band would be there the loading
control band would be there but there
would be no band for b so from this from
this particular graph we can say that
these
two proteins a and b are not interacting
most likely they are not interacting but
from this graph we can say that protein
a and protein b are interacting because
we have first pulled down a with a
particularly monoclonal antibody coated
bit and then in that pulldown fraction
we are able to show that b is present so
we can say that inside the cell in vivo
situation a and b are interacting
together that is why we are seeing the
band in the b
i hope you enjoyed this video
and this video is useful to you and if
you like my video please give it a quick
thumbs up and thank you and don't forget
to subscribe